so history was made at the world series
of poker dan cates won back-to-back
poker player championship titles along
with 1.4 million in prize money and he
is back on the show with us now
congratulations my friend thank you it's
great to see you again yeah thanks for
having me on the show i'm happy to be on
okay how did it feel to win again what
was the moment you won what did it feel
like it felt kind of unbelievable i like
didn't barely believe in myself i was
like sort of joking when i said out they
never stand a chance blah blah
intercontinental champion
i was just like kind of playing it up
totally but and then i won i was like
okay cool you did it again and you were
you always get dressed up which i love
about watching you're always dressed up
in character you're dressed up as macho
man randy savage oh yeah
yeah yeah well macho man dan the dan
version
your own spin on it yeah what was the
macho man inspiration for you uh well
macho man was like way over the top and
he dressed in crazy outfits and i
thought he kind of looked like me too
there we go yeah we see right there yeah
you know um i
the whole intercontinental thing the
whole defender title thing reminded me
of wrestling
of like fighting and like of how cocky
these guys were like i even brought a
towel like so they my opponents could
cry when they lost
you make it entertaining yeah that's the
idea you know
i i read was that the final match or
hand went went 15 hours is that true uh
yeah the final day was
13 15 hours something like that are you
playing 13 hours straight yeah you take
a bathroom break or just go nonstop oh
there's a couple breaks but you know i'm
used to this i've been doing this for 14
years but yeah it would be intense for a
lot of people that aren't so used to
this and have to you know aren't
thinking making poker decisions every
single day and that kind of thing for
people that are just joining us right
now and seeing you you you're the goat i
mean when it comes to poker i mean you
are you're the top you're the best of
the best it doesn't get any better than
you
what do you have here is this part of
your winnings this bracelet this is the
bracelet this was the thing i was
defending so that no one else could take
it
uh yeah that's what you get if you win
on top of the actual prize money i mean
i want the prize money more but i'll
take breakfast so i can wear
where it's in uh show it off or whatever
because you're the champ okay i know i'm
not supposed to talk about money but i
have to ask 1.4 million you won this
time that brings your total winnings to
what
uh depends on what resource you're
looking at because
my total winnings would be somewhere
over 20 million
20 million dollars i love it
that's awesome
thank you there's something to be proud
of
yeah what's next another tournament what
do you think should you now relax go on
vacation what's next for you a couple
things are a bit confidential but uh i'm
i tend to try to keep myself busy with
many different things um
i uh oh i did promise i was gonna give
some money to charity uh as after
winning and also invest in social
enterprise which i believe is
even more beneficial in fact than
charity a different uh longer subject
but yeah i'm gonna invest in helping
kids with their education primarily
early intervention education i mean i
promise to do that i'm gonna do that
okay i love it yeah well you always get
back dan thank you so much for joining
us the champ is here with us again we
appreciate it uh continued success my
friend jillian we'll send it over to you